hello all
and welcome to api 302 graphql
building a consistent approach for the
api consumer my name is dave foyer the
head of global platform strategy at
apogee a part of google cloud platform
and i'm joined today by miguel mendoza a
lead architect at apogee a part of
google cloud platform
today we're going to go over what is
graphql what it's good for
and what are the sim similarly expected
features that are missing from graphql
secondly we're going to go over
consistency what's the point of
consistency and walk through of
rest-based practices
and then translating that to graphql
lastly miguel mendoza is going to do a
demo for us
of how we would implement some of this
on top of apogee the first thing i'd
like to say is that graphql is awesome
graphql has some terrific benefits and
if i had to break down some of these
benefits
i would break them down to three key
areas the fact that there's a single
endpoint so all the data is exchanged
performing a single endpoint
so granularity for data load and
execution of requests in parallel
query planning all that is super
straightforward in graphql
the second is an incredibly powerful
query language
that prevents over-fetching and
under-fetching of data as opposed to
let's say in rest where many of the
requests
have to be sequential and then lastly
graphql client libraries
so graphql is no longer only the domain
of the react.js
ui framework but it's also available for
other client libraries and for other
languages and paradigms
so that graphql is truly useful to most
developers today
so why isn't graphql everywhere i think
ultimately this comes down to a
bifurcation that we're seeing in the
market
the first is that developer programs are
frequently
separated from api programs developer
programs
tend to be external facing or
interfacing between business units
so that the author of the server and
client are different
in apis frequently what we see is that
the author of the client and server
are a tight-knit group of people or the
same person and that's what we're seeing
more of graphql
and i think part of that has to do with
consistency and we'll talk about that
today
but fundamentally self-service developer
programs are a growth strategy and so
developer programs are a way of getting
internal partner and external developers
leveraging your apis
as opposed to api programs which are
typically an infrastructure strategy
driving interoperability and
decomposition of your internal
infrastructure
so what are the benefits of graphql why
use graphql
well we talked a little bit about some
of the differences let's do a little bit
of a deep dive right
rest has multiple different endpoints
and a url taxonomy that's used as a
logical resource manager
for different types of apis in graphql
there's really one endpoint
and longer and larger queries for
customer data encapsulate
all the different value and different
value propositions that you would
normally see
in those different urls in rest in
interactions
rest uses http verbs and generally uses
json and xml in order to exchange the
data
in graphql graphql uses post most of the
time and also
leverages different query types
specified inside the protocol
not in http so there's no verbs they're
just a custom query language
called schema definition language so
even though it's a custom query language
on the request
json is returned which makes it much
easier for clients but there's a
significant difference in the
interaction mechanism
documentation is different whether it's
open api specs and portals on the rest
side
really in in graphql there's a schema
generated documentation
frequently it will see customers using
graphical or graphql playground
in order to interact with schema based
graphql endpoints and then of course
from a discovery perspective
the portal is the playground in rest
where a customer would normally go or a
developer would normally go
to discover and interact with rest apis
in order to understand how they work
in graphql the portal actually is a
built-in playground that accommodates
development it's almost like a built-in
ide
and so it allows you to explore new
queries on the fly and use things like
tab completion in order to discover
those queries in order to
learn how to use them better and so
we're not here to talk about whether you
should use graphql or rest
our philosophy is that you should use
graphql and rest
and i think one of the best ways to do
that is to take some of our rest-based
practices and apply them to graphql
this is something that we've seen in the
market this is something that we really
see working really well in a number of
customers and so we wanted to bring
those to you
so that you could leverage them and
understand what those are
the basis of this philosophy is that
apis are digital products
apis are a way for an enterprise to take
its assets and put it in the hands of
developers
whether those developers are internal
employees partners
or external customers in order to grow
the company's leverage of those assets
because apis are digital products we
rely on developers having a consistent
experience
in order to understand how to use those
digital products and build the
compelling experiences
they need in order to bring your assets
to market
and so consistency is incredibly
important because developer friction
is a is a huge challenge in
adoption of apis and in growth
strategies of digital companies
consistency in graphql really starts
with well-formed graphql and i think we
can learn a lot about that from
well-formed rest
you would never expect a well-formed
rest query to be list employees by
department
that sounds like a java function a
well-conformed rest query would be
a resource right get employees and you
pass employees id
and so that is what we consider wealth
and rest right nouns and those nouns are
plural graph hierarchy is fundamentally
a data-driven hierarchy
right so why do we frequently treat it
like a functional hierarchy
well-formed graphql shouldn't look like
the java functions which it frequently
does
well form graphql should look like
well-formed rest
why not use books and titles and authors
and treat this graphical hierarchy
the way it should be treated as opposed
to treating it as a functional hierarchy
and so the first recommendation we have
is that you should be data-oriented
a graph hierarchy is fundamentally a
data-driven hierarchy
be data-driven treat it that way don't
be so function-oriented
the second recommendation has to do with
submitting and retrieving data
those are not always mirrored operations
we frequently see and rest
leverage of cqrs right we see retrieving
data from multiple services in a
microservice architecture
being completely separate from how to
submit that data
and so as we think about how to do this
in graphql
we specifically think that mutations the
way a graphql developer submits data
can get very complex very quickly
especially when there's a lot of
different types
and especially when submitting very
little data and so
don't be afraid of cqrs many of you have
heard of cqrs which is command query
responsibility segregation
it's a design pattern that was first
identified by martin fowler
and fundamentally it's just a different
model to update information than the
model you use to read information
and so we're seeing in graphql programs
especially in large enterprises
especially those enterprises that
already have rest is that you get the
advantage
of using a rest-based front-end by
retrieving the data with graphql
but leveraging your existing rest apis
in order to submit that data to your
backend
the third pattern i'd like to talk about
is optimizing for reusability
you know in rest we think a lot about
our url taxonomy pagination filtering
and creating consistency
because developers can then predict what
the behavior will be of an api call
a developer sees the rest api and goes
aha i know how to interact with this
well in graphql we should be doing the
same thing
the challenge in large enterprise
graphql deployments
is that when it comes to schema
stitching frequently different business
units different lines of business
are developing different aspects to the
schema and then stitching that together
in order to look like
one comprehensive representation one big
graph to hand to an external developer
the behavior that json returned though
is frequently different
because there's no consistency it wasn't
built as an api product
as part of a developer program it was
built as an internal api
sort of a functional way of interacting
between components so when we think
about relay cursor connections
and input hints all the uniform behavior
that you would expect in a rest api
should
also exist in the graphql api so in
graphql we should be very careful about
optimizing for reusability
and avoiding situations where the
developer is confused or otherwise
doesn't understand
why the behavior is different in one
part of the schema
than it is in another part of the schema
and this is particularly a problem with
mutations
because uh if you submit data to one
part of the schema one way
and it gets recorded one way you don't
always realize that when you submit it
in another part of the schema
it got recorded another way so mutations
are even a larger
uh a larger surface area of challenges
when it comes to
optimizing for reusability and api
prioritization and so we particularly be
afraid there
uh be particularly conscientious
of the way you develop and design
mutations in graphql
lastly i want to talk about field names
because this is something that miguel
and i have experienced personally
it is developer hostile to provide
different data and behavior
for field names with the same name in
different parts of the schema
so if there is a name field in one part
of the schema
that accepts first middle last name and
then there's a name field and another
part of the schema
that expects uh last name dot first name
that is developer hostile
you are not treating our developers the
way they expect to be requested
the way they expect to be treated and
your developers will free
you will frequently experience developer
abandonment because your developers will
struggle
to adopt your graphql api so avoid the
graphical anti-patterns
treat the graph as a data-driven
hierarchy don't force graphql use rest
where and when it makes sense
and lastly optimize for reusability
think about api products think about the
developer experience and treating the
developer
as the customer they are because you
want your graphql api
to be used and you want it to get to
market
there are challenges in graphql
deployments and i'm going to go over
these challenges very quickly because i
think we're all somewhat familiar with
them
often z authorization authentication is
a huge challenge
as you know the graphql spec delegates
authenzy to the business logic layer
which means that it's typically not
handled
by the graphql server throttling is a
challenge there's no standard like we
see in api productization
for creating different levels and
different tiers of service
and different access to different api
developers
the third is analytics there's no
unified view of analytics which means
leveraging apis as products raising apis
to the level of business analytics as
opposed to just operational metrics is
not something that's
possible and lastly versioning ops we
don't understand
how versioning works in graphql and how
particularly
to address the need for clients using
different versions of different schemas
in order to implement their applications
so now you know what to do how do you do
it
for that i'd like to introduce miguel
apogee is a highly extensible and
customizable platform with great
out-of-the-box features
but there are ways to do other things
with it there's fire support for
healthcare there's open banking support
for financial services companies
and much more including graphql with
that
i'd like to hand over to miguel miguel
take it away
all right so first let's take a look at
an overview of the architecture for this
demo
on the left side we have the apigee
developer portal and in this developer
portal we have
the graphql playground embedded within
the ipg developer portal
next we have the ipd api gateway which
is fronting
apollo graphql the apollo graphql server
is running
in cloud run within the apollo graphql
server there are also a couple of apigee
plugins
that send login and tracing data to gcp
throughout this demo we're going to dive
into each of these components left to
right one at a time
let's go ahead and get started first
let's go and take a look at the
developer portal
i already have navigated to the
developer portal so let me go to that
tab
here in the developer portal this is a
an rpg drupal developer portal
that has the graphql playground embedded
as you can see here
the plugin has already been loaded with
an endpoint this endpoint is the
rpg endpoint that from the apollo
graphql server
we can take a quick look at the docs tab
and we'll see the
schema that has been loaded into the
playground all right let's take a look
at it
so this schema represents a company that
aggregates
trail and lift data for ski resource so
you can see
the top level we have a ski resort data
type
and within this q resort type we have
different information and some of that
information is
trails and lift data let me show you a
quick diagram
that shows this schema
you can see here the resort type and
then under that we have trails and leaf
data
this is the reading or the query schema
there's also a mutation schema but i
won't show that yet we'll go that later
so let's head back into the developer
portal let's run a query that lists
all the resources that are available so
we do a query
list all resource
and for each resort let's just pull the
name of the resort
and we can run this query and you can
see that we have three resources
kirkwood sierra tao and heavenly now if
i keep trying to run this query multiple
times let's see what happens
you can see oh and we had an error so we
have a raid limit error
this is rpg that has detected that
the client has sent too many requests
over a certain period of time so the
within apigee is running a quota policy
and that policy rejected the call
so how do we get around this one way to
get around this is to
actually get an api key and maybe make a
call using a specific api key that has a
higher and higher entitlement
in terms of calls per minute so let's do
that notice i am not even logged in
apigee rejected the call based on the
client ip address and the number of
calls originating from that address
so let's go ahead and log in so that we
can create an app and get an api key
i already have an account that i created
earlier so let me just log in with that
account
so now let's go ahead and create an app
and i'm going to call my app peter
app and for this app i'm going to select
the graphql
bronze api product this product has a
higher entitlement
so that i will be able to make calls
without being worried so much about the
number of calls per minute
all right so my app has been created now
i should be able to get the api key
from this app let's grab the api key and
secret for this app
all right so here we have the new app
that was created and
we'll grab the api key or the consumer
key and the consumer secret
i'm going to open the graphql player in
a new tab that way i can just copy paste
these values over there so let me copy
the consumer key
all right so back here in the graphql
playground let's use the consumer key
and the consumer secret
so in apigee we have modified the
graphql playground slightly to make this
this experience a little bit smoother
so on the top right here you can see
client credentials button so this is a
widget that we have added
for expressly for this purpose so let's
click on here
and let's add the client id
right so we have client id next let's
grab the client secret
or the consumer secret
and let's go back in here and paste a
consumer secret
and you can also see the scopes are
going to be requested
so basically this is an uh proper
flower that we're going to be doing and
we're going to be requesting a token
that has
introspection and reading reader scopes
let's get a token
all right great so we have a token so
this token came from apg itself
and we can take a look at the token
itself and you can see there's some
details about the token
and we have the reader scope
so let's go ahead and close this now we
should be able to run this query
multiple times with
this token that we just got using the
api key let's do that
and you can see now that we're not
hitting this new limit that we were
hitting earlier
cool so we're not getting that error
anymore so you can see that
since we got the api key and we were
able to get a token with a proper scope
that error has gone away what if we want
to do something else now let's say we
want to
add a resort to the you know to the
current data set
let's take a look at the you know the
schema for the mutations
so if we look at mutations we have a
resource mutation
and if we want to create a resort in
this case this follows more like a you
know almost like a rest crud example
create
you know delete update so
intuitively to create a resource we will
go here into the you know create
resource mutation
and you can see that the create resource
mutation takes a create resort input
and this is this is the data that we're
going to be passing in to create a new
resort so let's go ahead and do this
ah one more thing so notice that you
know it's documented here that in order
to
you know run the resource mutation you
need the site admin scope
you'll see how that comes into play in a
second
so let's try to run a mutation for
creating a resort
create new resort
and this is going to be the resource
mutation and under the resource mutation
we're going to go
on create and for create
we're going to pass an input and this
input we're going to give the name of
the resort let's say this is going to be
northstar
and the base elevation let's say
three 6300 feet and it's summit
elevation
eight thousand five hundred feet and
after we create the new resort
um let's let's pull up the id of the
resort that we just created
and the name of the resort
all right this should be good let's try
around this now
and oh we got an error so again this is
apigee
returning there this is not coming from
the backend graphql server
rpg is saying hey you're not authorized
to create a resort you don't have access
to
these fields so you don't you cannot
access the you know resource
uh mutation to and the resource mutation
create
so these fields are not authorized with
the current key or the current token
that i have
so how do we make this work obviously
the token that we have right now
let's take a look at it again this token
it only has this you know two scopes
introspection and reader scopes
and in order to be able to run this
mutation
according to the documentation we need
this you know site admin scope
so in order to get a token that has a
setup scope we need to have access to an
api product that offers that
scope or that offers those scopes so
let's take a look
back at the api products so if we go
back into
the app that we created earlier this app
will subscribe to the graphql bronze
product this graphql bronze product
does not offer the sidearm scope for in
order to
have to get this item in scope i need
access to another product so i have
already created another app called
shredder
and this app has access to graphql
platinum so the graphql platinum product
gives us a higher level of access in
terms of you know different parts of the
schema that we can access
and this you know product has already
been approved
and it's enabled for this app so let's
switch to use the key and secret for
you know this other app
all right let's grab the consumer key
and bring it over here
next let's get the secret
and finally let's change the scope to
site admin
so this scope will give us access to a
different part of the schema
now let's get a token and we have a new
token
hopefully now with this new token we
should be able to make the call to
create a new resort
let's do that great and you can see the
call is successful and we can verify
that it was successful by
listing all the resources again so let's
do that
all right so we get our resource let's
get the names of all the resorts
and you can see here northstar has been
created
alright so you have seen two important
key functionalities that apg is adding
on top of the existing graphql backend
first you saw throttling and then you
saw field level authorization
now let's appear behind the curtain to
see how that is done within apd let me
bring up the architecture diagram
just to remind you where we are so we're
looking so far at the developer portal
next we're going to look at the apigee
api gateway to see how those
throttling and field level authorization
were actually happening
all right let's head over to the api ui
great so here this this is a proxy that
was driving the entire experience you've
been using so far
the first policies that you can see here
these are course level authorization
policies it's just saying hey
do you even have a valid you know token
that
allows you to call this api then we have
the throttling
policy or the quota policy that checks
are you allowed to make you know the
number of calls you're making making so
far
and finally we have the fine grain
authorization policy
that checks whether or not the current
token has the correct level of access
for the fields
within the specific query or the
specific mutation
that's being sent to the graphql server
let's take a look at the quota policy
you can see this policy has been
configured with a default value of
five calls per minute this is in fact
the behavior you saw initially when i
was making those first calls to get the
list of resources
later once i created an app and
subscribed my app to the
bronze or the graphql bronze api product
i was able to make more calls
and that's defined outside that's
defined in the product itself
so if we look at the graphql bronze
product
you can see that the graphql browse
product has defined a quota of
30 requests per minute
next let's look at how the fine grain
authorization was working
here you can see in the graphql bronze
product that i have defined a set of
allowed auth scopes these are
introspection and reader scope
i also have the other product which is
the graphql platinum
which has an even bigger set of oscopes
in addition to introspection and reader
scope it's got resort admin resort
manager and site admin
remember we use site admin when we went
when we went to create the new resort
so this is great you can see how you're
able to manage both the
sla the throttling level and the fine
grain authorization to
the graphql endpoint all within apigee
using the concept of api products
now you may be asking yourself how are
these scopes being translated to
individual
fields in the graphql schema let's take
a look at that next
all right so how do we go from a scope
to an actual set of fields or an
entitlement
to do that we have stored the
configuration of a mapping of
scopes to fields in apigee itself and
let's take a look at that this is in an
rpg
kvm key value map so this is starting
here and let me open it so you can see
for each scope i have listed here
the entitlement or the set of fields
that this
scope is allowed to access and in the
case of earlier we're look we're using
the site admin scope
and you can see the cytamin has access
to mutation resource and mutation
resource
wildcard which means that if you have
the satellite scope
your token is allowed to access any of
these
types within the graphql schema all
right so let's go back to the proxy and
put it all together
so the first policy that runs is the
authorization policy this is
course level authorization it just
checks hey do you have a token
and and once you have that token it
extracts the
uh basically the scopes that you have
associated with that token it also
verifies that this token is allowed to
access the proxy itself it doesn't check
individual fields
but it extracts the scopes then you have
the quota policy that checks in hey you
know are you still within your
allowed limits and then you have the
fine grain authorization policy
for this fine grain authorization policy
it basically takes the
scope that was associated with the token
that came in and converts that scope to
a set of entitlements or a set of fields
and it checks that the set of
entitlements or the set of fields
that are allowed for this token satisfy
all the fields that came in in the
specific query or the specific mutation
and if that's the case then apigee will
go ahead and let the call through
and go to the graphql backend and if not
then api returns an error
next let's take a look at what happens
after application sequel over to the
actual graphql back-end server
let me bring up the architecture diagram
again
so the call came in from the developer
portal arrived at the apigee api gateway
rpg checked the call for security course
level and
fine grain field level authorization it
also did you know throttling checks
and then it sent the call over to the
actual apollo graphql server
this server i have it running in gcp in
cloud run
and within here i have the apollo server
i have added a couple of apigee plugins
that allow you to send data over to gcp
cloud login and also to cloud tracing
and this data is sent asynchronously in
batches so it's not it does not affect
the runtime of the main call itself
let's hop over to the google cloud
console and take a look at some of this
data
here i have the gcp log viewer and i'm
showing the
create new resort mutation that we ran
earlier you can see the actual payload
for the mutation is being logged as well
as the time stamp for this mutation
all right let's go over to the trace
great so
here each of these dots represent an
individual query or mutation that has
been sent to the
apollo graphql server and i have
selected already here the mutation
that was run to create the north star
resort you can see the trace information
shows
how long it took to fetch each
individual field
in that mutation this is all data that
is produced by apollo itself
and is being shipped off to google cloud
and shown here in the trace view
so this gives you a good view of the
individual timing and trace information
for
specific queries what if you want more
trend information or overtime
information of
the data itself apigee collects
analytics information for every request
that comes through the system
so let's go over and take a look at some
of that
let me switch to apigee analytics so
here i have created a custom report in
apigee
that takes a look at the individual
fields that were fetched
for queries over time and also mutations
as they
you know passed through the apg gateway
and this data has been enhanced
with the timing information provided by
apollo itself you can see that it shows
different fields how many times each of
those fields have been
fetched and the average response time
that it takes to
retrieve those fields you can also
create other types of reports with this
data it's not just limited to fields
you can do different aggregations maybe
per client you know which clients are
requesting what kind of fields
in fact let's drill down into one of
this
so you can see here that the differing
apps uh for example a product playground
app is requesting
you know some traffic over here and then
you know the
peter app which is the one i created is
also has some traffic for the resource
name
hopefully this gives you an idea of you
know how powerful both combining apigee
analytics with the cloud tracing data
and the cloud logging data can be
to enhance the information that you can
get for the traffic going through your
graphql server
well folks that's it for the demo now
let me hand it back to you david
that was awesome mcgill thank you so
what are three things
you can do today with graphql if you use
apogee to manage your apis you're one
step closer to your destination
go download the graphql github sample
and play with it we'd love to hear your
feedback
if you're not an average user go to
apogee.com
try out the free version of apogee use
graphql or don't
and do cool stuff we'd love to hear
about that as well and lastly
if you're a graphql user and you want to
learn about the best place to build apis
google cloud's cloud run is an awesome
backend for your graphql serverless
applications
definitely check it out thank you so
much for your time today and we look
forward to seeing you and hearing from
you throughout the week